I was told by a drama teacher that I
might do okay if I was happy to settle
for the fat girl parts you know if you
believe that there's something you want
to do and you want to be successful at
it it will not just come to you you do
have to keep practicing things you have
to allow yourself to make mistakes the
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation what's that belief nation it's
even my one word is believe and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from being bullied as a child for being
overweight to dropping out of school at
age 16 to becoming a successful and
award-winning actress she's Kate Winslet
and here's my take on her top ten rules
of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't listen to the little man when
I was younger when I was only 14 I was
told by a drama teacher that I might do
okay if I was happy to settle for the
fat girl parts and so what I feel like
saying in those moments is you know any
young woman who has ever been put down
by a teacher or a friend or even a
parent just don't listen to any of it
because that's what I did I didn't
listen and I kept on going and I
overcame all of my fears and I got over
a lot of insecurities and and just keep
doing it and keep believing in yourself
you know that's what I felt like I
really had to dig deep and do rule
number two
be driven by fear I lived my life you
know and every time I'm cast in a film I
am equally as terrified as I was about
the challenge when I did my first film
in seventeen and when I did Titanic and
when I did it turn on sometime of the
spotless mind and when I did the reader
you know that fear I think is what
drives me to be honest you know acting
it's such a wonderful thing to do and I
I love it and I and I love it more as
I'm getting older I think but it is
scary because you can easily get it
wrong rule number three persevere I have
always felt in my core that I wanted to
be an actress always I always thought
that if I was lucky enough for it for it
to work out I would I'd be on the stage
and actually when I got was cast in an
episode one episode of a TV series in
England when I was 16 my god that was
huge Dale that was a huge deal an
episode of a TV series and it paid me
equity minimum which in that was a lot
of money for me in those days and how I
began though even though I was 16 being
cast you know this small part in this TV
series in the year later I was cast in
heavenly creatures which was the first
film I ever did prior to that you know
I'd been I'd been auditioning a lot
between the age of about 12 and and
Dean and I never got the parts never and
actually more often than not because my
name began with the W I would be at the
back of the queue and they would just
run out of time so everyone from kind of
T onwards would just be sent home and
you wouldn't even get a look in and I
was always wearing the wrong clothes my
hair had always got static it's just in
the moment when you really didn't want
it to have static I never had any makeup
because there was never any money for
makeup and even if I had done it were I
would have stole them my mother's all
full sort of plumb from the body shop
that would have been smushed by both my
other two sisters by then and so but
also I was as a kid I was I was bullied
at school because I was always quite
chubby I was always overweight and I was
always told I was wrong I was doing the
wrong thing I was sort of made to feel
ashamed of of myself my appearance
everything about myself I was the
slowest runner
I was just everything was wrong and you
know you develop a sort of a
self-preservation muscle when you
experienced something like that but I
did always love acting and I would
always feel quite smug about the fact
that I had this one thing that I really
loved and I didn't have to go anywhere
or do anything to be able to do it I
could literally close my bedroom door
and just go on ahead and do it in the
mirror like
for hours at a time I could practice
making myself cry I could practice doing
on-screen make-out sessions I could just
do it and and I knew that nobody else in
my class at school had any understanding
of how great that feeling was and that
honestly is something that I have always
hung on to no matter what rule number
four
be brave after Titanic you you had so
many interesting career choice as I
thought I mean really interesting much
smaller movies they must have come to
you and said do this do that do that and
the choices you made were really
terrific little movies that are not the
obvious choices that you would make
after that kind of assist well you know
Pete I had to be really brave yeah you
know I did have to be I did have to be
really brave because it was a moment in
time and suddenly I was offered quite
big films I mean suddenly a lot came my
way quite quickly and I mean I can't
even talk about the size of these
paychecks I just and I just remember
thinking I'm not I'm honestly not ready
I don't I don't I still don't feel like
I know how to do this I don't know how
to act properly I need to learn more I
can't I can't do it I'm not ready for
that and also I wasn't ready to be that
famous I didn't I didn't like that
feeling yeah I mean honestly I really
didn't and I knew that I wasn't prepared
to fuel it I didn't want to follow suit
with something else that was where
nothing was going to top Titanic nothing
and I was just very lucky at the time
had some very very good friends around
me who would just say you've got to
you've got to make sure that you you're
doing what is making you happy and at
the same time it was of course very
difficult to be turning down gigantic
films because I'm so lucky to be asked
to do them in the first place and I
hadn't auditioned for those I mean my
god I couldn't believe that they just
call you up and so it was a it was I
mean it sounds terribly sort of
ungrateful but I just knew that I needed
to look after my desire to learn more
and
and also I was I wasn't very experienced
I needed to be out in the world and and
and some of the films that I was able to
do after Titanic like like hideous kinky
Holy Smoke for example they took me into
the world you know either Arauco into a
Medina in Marrakesh and you know off
into the Flinders Ranges in the outback
in Australia and you know so III was
living I was living a life that was my
life and my choices and not something
that everyone else was saying to me are
you crazy what do you what do you know
you crazy good you've got to do this and
you have to do that and you know I said
well I'm just I can't I'm not I'm not
ready
well yeah and it was quite I had to be
quite I did have to be quite brave rule
number five work hard do you think that
we live in a time now where it's quite
easy to get a sort of full sense of
celebrity or fame and to aspire towards
celebrity and fame without even taking
into account the steps that you need to
take to get to achieve that thing
[Music]
I think it's making young people lose
that sense of work ethic you know if you
believe that there's something you want
to do and you want to be successful at
it it will not just come to you you have
to work towards achieving that goal you
know no one else is gonna achieve it for
you it's you've only got yourself to
rely on rule number six trust your
instincts as I get older my roles are
getting more and more interesting and I
cannot believe that I mean I have been
so blessed but the last two three years
in particular since really 2005 it's
just been utterly incredible and it is
me that chooses it really is even some
you know sometimes go for something that
will surprise my agents and they go
really Wow okay well you know we didn't
think you were going to go for that one
but I just I just really trust my
instinct you know sometimes it's
literally a knee-jerk reaction sometimes
I'll hear a title of a script and I'll
say to Sam oh you know he'll dat whose
major los angeles who i've been with
since i was 17
hilda sending a script it's called
such-and-such i've got a feeling about
it and then i'll read it and go there
you go there's like little children it
was exactly that happened so I'm sending
your script poor little children I went
oh oh I mean it's it's really odd it's
very very weird it's and it can
sometimes be a tiny thing like that but
it's it's it's it's a purely instinctive
thing for me rule number seven
stay focused there are challenges in
every single day the biggest one to be
honest with you I think is being able to
stay focused because you can rehearse
and you can plan everything then you can
think you have a you know a framework
that you want to stick with or a few
ideas that you want to remember to keep
in your back pocket and sometimes the
craziness of an on-set environment can
be so intense that you can find yourself
for getting all of those things that you
planned so actually really really
staying focused and knowing that it's
okay to kind of take yourself off into a
quiet corner and just remember what it
was he who set out to do rule number
eight believe hunter who's 11
wants to know what kind of advice can
you give an eleven-year-old like me
who's just starting who's in the second
year in the industry and what keeps you
motivated with all the rejection
you know hunter self-esteem first of all
don't listen to him hunter you know what
the most important thing is the most
important thing is that you believe that
you're meant to be an actor don't you
well then you will be that's the most
important thing and that that is the key
thing to remember and kind of trick
yourself to like when you go into
auditions say to yourself they should be
lucky to have me
you just say that you're not smug about
it you just quietly say that to yourself
and remember that they would be lucky to
have you
okay that's what you remember rule
number 9 be driven you have a plethora
of awards I didn't mention from BAFTA to
Golden Globes and teens and and so many
Oski I think you're still the youngest
person to amass six nominations and then
seven nominations and that keeps
following you but does that ever get old
to you to get that kind of recognition
no I mean I just I I don't know how else
to put it it's it still matters I still
care it's still a huge thrill it's still
a gigantic honor I I think as I get
older I'm only more and more aware of
just how how tough it is to keep doing
good work and to keep that bar as high
as it as it should be you know and and I
love the job so much and I love the
experience of making films probably more
than ever I think and I feel like I said
that last year and I felt like I
probably said it the year before but but
this year I feel like I really mean it
it's um
I don't know it's uh it's it's it's such
a blessing to to do a job and and be
employed to do the thing that you love I
mean it's it's you know there are so few
actors in the world who are employed to
do what they love and and I just don't
take any of it lightly at all and so no
for me it's still no it will never get
tired none of it and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is keep at it I think what I would
honestly say to
people starting out you know it is
difficult it is definitely a hard job to
do and and you do have to keep working
at it you do have to keep practicing
things you have to allow yourself to
make mistakes you know make them
rehearse in your bedroom try not to look
in the mirror too much because then you
can you rehearse the scene in front of a
mirror and you like the way you've said
something or done something and all you
will do is keep picturing yourself doing
it the way you liked rather than being
completely present in the moment have no
looking in mirrors that's not good you
have to keep at it so you do and if it
is the thing that you really believe you
want to do with your life you will get
there you just have to keep going and
keep going and keep going and keep
yourselves busy you know don't wait for
the phone to ring you know fill your
life in other areas because the more you
enrich your life the more enriched your
be as a as an actor and as a person and
you'll be able to bring much more to
each role that you hopefully will get
the chance to play now I've got a really
special bonus clip from Kate on how to
not give up that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're feeling
bold answer these three questions in the
comments below here we go
question number one what fear drives you
number two what instinct do you need to
trust more and number three which little
man do you need to stop listening to
[Music]
what advice would I give to an aspiring
actress or actor the thing I do find
myself saying often is you should just
don't ever give up if acting is
something that you feel is in your veins
and in your DNA and and you just want to
do it and believe that you should and
believe that you can then if you keep
believing that enough and you keep
working hard because it's not going to
be handed you want to plate then that's
more important than anything else
determination and confidence will get
you everywhere especially when you walk
into an audition room because if you
walk into an audition room and you're
terrified and desperate then they'll
smell it on you and you're less likely
to get the job if you just believe in
yourself and you work hard and you walk
in there and bring confidence and good
positive energy with you you're much
more likely to get another looking
[Music]
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would become
like a little beacon
if you like this video check out Kate's
Titanic co-star Leonardo DiCaprio's top
10 Rose a success I think you're gonna
like it the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there but I got up and I he said now is
it empty is it empty and I got up and I
screamed